part four of sending quizzes to the guys  that have ghosted me next up we have  tyrell and for photo reference this is  him how would you rate my conversation  skills he gave me a nine  is there any specific reason you stopped  talking to me he said  nothing you did i just got caught up in  life stuff when did you decide that you  did not want to talk to me anymore he  said i never made a conscious decision  just got distracted but now i'm off the  market would it have changed things if  you knew i could make  really good french toast probably not we  didn't live close enough for it to have  mattered in the short term  french toast is bomb af though why did  you decide to do it without warning he  said now i feel bad  any final words this was fun how  uncomfortable were you taking this form  he gave me a3  so closer to not at all